[Applaudissements]
j'ai dit non
est-ce que l'intérêt des africains est
d'organiser une coupe d'afrique
chaque quatre années je ne pense pas je
pense que l'intérêt plutôt du côté des
clubs européens qui voudraient avoir
pleinement leurs joueurs
[Applaudissements]
c'est plus l'intérêt des clubs européens
qui est qui et c'est d'avoir un stade
you man et c'est d'avoir un mohamed
salah qui nous représente aujourd'hui
d'avoir aubameyang
c'est ça l'intérêt des clubs gandhi
grand club se réunissent peut-être avec
un président et qui lui disent écoute
non à ces difficultés
est ce que on peut faire ça comme la
coupe du monde tu qu'on veut nous
imposer
est ce que nous avons besoin la caf
reste la confédération africain tout
fait
[Musique]